this is Startalk welcome to Startalk
radio I'm your host Bill Nye the Science
Guy and with me today is Eugene Mirman
alone hello bill
wait where's Neal Neal yeah Neil Tyson
deGrasse Tyson yeah I think he's got a
television gig he's busy he's gone he
asked me to sit in but I am doing my
best to have good posture also with us
today Eugene is Mike Massimino from NASA
unlike many of us flown in space call a
mass yeah that's good
call me mass good to be here bill thanks
how you doing Eugene good good to see
you Mike Mike you're you're in New York
I am I'm uh I'm at Columbia University
as a visiting professor I'm on loan from
NASA I'm teaching a space related course
introduction to human spaceflight and
enjoying being in New York City let me
ask you this so deskaway this is the
introduction to human space that's right
or is there like 200 to 10 to 300 level
courses how many courses do I take in
human spaceflight this is the
introduction so we'll start with this
and we'll see how this one go if I can
one at a time if you take that if it
goes well we'll see where we want to go
from it is that enough to kind of go in
like how much more than your class what
I need to go into space you would need a
lot Eugene but all of us need a lot a
lot but this will give you the basics of
what you need to learn say I took your
class and had I don't know eighty-five
billion dollars with that to get with
those two things because 85 billion you
don't need my class in fact I would
recommend it what a waste buddy no in
that case I would say don't waste your
time if you figured out a way to make 85
million dollars and you want to spend it
on a space flight I would go straight to
that option okay well gentlemen this is
the cosmic queries edition of sorry talk
radio and we have queries yeah
from out there from the social media yes
from Facebook Twitter probably photos on
Instagram of questions the tumblr all
the thing all the things that kids are
using with your electric computer
machines take solid kids yeah a lot of
nah well yeah we'll see
so my understanding is Eugene you know
radio
a visual medium out there he's got some
papers yeah I have some papers with peep
questions that people wrote in about
NASA and Planetary Science funding and
I'm going to read them so let's try one
let's do it will Burke asks what is the
biggest stumbling block for NASA to get
funding is it stubborn legislators
science illiteracy or other factors
what's the best way we can change it
mass um I I think that NASA does it does
get funding we always could use more
yeah I think it's general you know yeah
but I think it's just how we how we
value things you know if we would value
the science that comes out of the space
program more I think people would be
willing to to pay more for it
exploration International I think a lot
of people don't understand all the
things that NASA does what are what are
like internet let's just take one thing
International Cooperation you might not
think of NASA with international
cooperation but a lot of this the
science programs we have particularly
International Space Station is internet
it's called the International parties
very hard to make friends with a Russian
on this planet but if you just go a
little into space everybody's friendly
well look about when I was a kid we
weren't necessarily front friends with
the Russians the Soviet Union the US are
in a cold war and yeah we fly into space
with these people all the time we're
really good friends with something I
think'll I think that's one benefit that
people don't realize the other thing
everybody for me science is important
and I love science and the science guy
after all
but what the space program brings us is
this optimism when you have a space
program no matter what country you are
you believe your society believes many
people believe that any problem can be
solved if you can put a man on the moon
we can make a car that goes over a
thousand miles we can do anything and
this is why all these countries you
might not think of having space programs
that you fly with yeah South Africa
what-have-you Australia on the back of
the Canadian Brazil Brazil has a space
program yeah go see Hans an action Harry
the tone of his voice yeah he was a
Jewess uh Norway edit them
and no no I didn't you just didn't
believe it yeah crazy Wow yes because
they know the value of having people
running around in your society doing
space solving space problems yeah and
the thing for me as the executive
director CEO of the Planetary Society is
charge yeah well is Planetary Sciences
where these new problems are being
solved trying to land a car on Mars is
an extraordinary undertaking and so when
you go to solve problems they've never
been solved before you just innovate
can't be helped
so that's the the value is selling
politicians of all sides of the of the
executive the judicial and the and the
congressional representative on the
value of space exploration so that's
that because the last part of that
question was what's the best way we can
change it what are like say for three
things voting vote on the the way that
people vote on particular issues vote on
the issue of science that's right well
especially space science space size yes
so people say why are you exploring Mars
what are you going to find there we
don't know that's why we're exploring
we're gonna probably find the technology
to make even better cell phones that's
people don't know that's that's
absolutely correct yeah yeah people do
have a voice in this for example the
Hubble Space Telescope which was I think
a very good combination of human
spaceflight and planetary science
forgery oh yeah all the smart people
come up with the discovery it had some
problems you do why that's my exit
that's reality had canceled the last
servicing mission it I was lucky to be
on dan cancel it and they got brought
back mainly because of public outrage
and politicians listening and I'm bill
I'm sure is a big part of that yeah I
wanted Hubble fix if we could only
degree of a voice we could only trick
al-qaeda into bombing something in outer
space
we'd be there that was what started the
whole thing was the ultimate high ground
we digress yes so vote person on the who
asked the question and let's change the
world okay
here's a next question from Chris Van
Gundy shouldn't the rest of the
government be begging NASA for money
well this is the old question you see
it's not do space exploration or provide
clean water for people who don't have it
or provide education for girls and women
so that they raise the standard of
living
improve the quality of life for all
citizens everywhere it's not one or the
other it's not NASA or build a new
baseball stadium you have to do
everything all at once right also
doesn't NASA investing in NASA then
literally has a very good return right
yeah in terms of the money the
government spends and it's not very much
it's less than one penny of your tax
dollar that goes to NASA yeah point four
percent and furthermore also in addition
to continue the current number is three
dollars and sixty cents for every dollar
that goes into NASA get three dollars
and sixty cents back that's pretty good
that's really it's very good because
some people will argue that highways are
slightly larger but highways in general
do not lead to innovation the way Space
Exploration does and it's some for the
future that's it's about the future
innovation is what's going to drive the
economy so anyway you guys pretty soon
we gotta take a break sold me on it we
got to take a break but I want you all
to out there to visit WWE talked radio
dotnet to find us on Twitter at star
talk radio check out Eugene Mirman at
Eugene Mirman and check out Mike at
Astro underscore Mike we'll see you in a
moment
welcome back to Startalk radio I'm Bill
Nye the Science Guy guest hosting for my
beloved colleague Neil deGrasse Tyson
I'm here with your favorite eugene
mirman and everybody's favorite
astronaut Mike Massimino call amass and
this is the cosmic query addition of
star talk radio and we have your queries
from the cosmos it is there's very
strong evidence that all of these
questions are from people within our
universe but maybe not we'll find out
take one let's let's go William Dyck
asks what are some of the current and
future strategies of privatized space
travel versus those of NASA or other
government based space programs what is
what is different about their strategies
and why what types of missions or
projects do you see these two sides
carrying out fifty or a hundred years
from now that's a lot of questions
people a lot of stuff terrified of only
asking one clear question it's of a
piece though it's all one thing the
difference is when people started
exploring space at NASA they weren't
trying to make money the modern idea is
that you could make money in space now
people make a lot of money in space with
communication satellites I don't want to
shock you all but there's this business
of inertial security agency and there's
certain spy satellites and there's a lot
of weather satellites and those data are
sold like crazy there's a lot of money
in rain yes right there is if you're a
farmer yeah you have great fascination
and so on with that said there are
extraordinary ideas let's go get an
asteroid and pull back the platinum yeah
but anyway those people believe they can
make money but note well a company like
SpaceX or Sierra Nevada space or or
XCore corporation Virgin Galactic or not
virtually but these companies take money
from the US government to promote or to
develop their rockets it's not it's not
a standalone business yet mass did you
get involved in that stuff yeah we work
in the three of the companies that are
trying to get us back to the with people
launching to the International Space
Station with astronauts
mentioned a couple of ex SpaceX mm-hmm
Nevada and Boeing or we have in Sierra
Nevada is not a soda company no it's not
no it's not it's not about beverages
okay although hopefully we will provide
beverages on their space wrench or need
water hey I got a question I'm sorry
yeah you guys really drink tang we drink
what we call orange flavored drink
because the name you mentioned mm-hmm no
braising is a brand right exactly so
everything we have like um let's let's
take a chance q-tip okay ah is not a
q-tip it's a cotton swab assembly and
always officially and what really good
was in a CSA it's a CNC cotton swab is a
CSA but we it but we want to make sure
we know what it is because CSA could
also be Canadian Space Agency or you're
a really mmunity supported and your
culture yeah you know yeah you know what
it really gets confusing though what is
when you need to take like any kind of
medicine or because it's all got that
does have the brand names oh so you
don't know but you know what like every
stuff is brands into space and just not
say them like if you ever had a candy
bar head that's a buy don't even that's
right well we have certain candy bars
that you get better we have certain
candy is very very popular cause they're
small and you can float them yeah and we
call them candy candy covered chocolate
you'll calm WWE and just Lego I'll get
back to this guys question everything
has its a generic name yeah so what we
have to narrate man for that product
which is orange flavored drink orange
flavored so while you're enjoying your
orange flavored drink it is to be hoped
that soon you will get up into
microgravity yes by means of rockets not
built exclusively by NASA correct and
that's what you know we Nessa has worked
with contractors right from the very
beginning with some of the big
government contractors right Rockwell
International for example the old joke
you got to the moon on the lowest bidder
that's correct all the part you know
Graham in all these companies all work
together to build spaceships funded by
the government so there is some
government funding going into those
those private companies as well so I
think it's a good partnership I think as
bill said they're trying to make money
yeah and so this could be a very very
exciting time and I'm noticing it my my
my position at Columbia with all these
young smart kids and these kids are a
lot smarter than I ever remember being
they are interested in the space program
just as much as we when we were kids but
it's not just NASA it's they're
interested in going to work for one of
these companies they say it's
entrepreneurship as the future and I
think that there's going to be hopefully
if you're optimistic about it a very
good relationship between the companies
and NASA in the future well NASA is a
sort of launching pad for a lot of
private launching I had that's brilliant
sorry - Wow how'd you read any more
let's try another that's the whole idea
all right here's another question from
Susan minnow people often complain about
the NASA budget and claim the private
industry should take over some of the
work that NASA does but they don't do it
already because the government but they
don't they do it already because of
government contracts what percent of the
NASA budget goes to private sector
contractors that that's the question
I don't know but it's got to be enormous
whenever you buy hardware you're buying
it from companies like Boeing yeah
United Launch Alliance or what have you
yeah NASA buy stuff from a lot of
companies but in a bit contractors to
work for me only have a certain number
of people working in the NASA workforce
how much stuff is built there I decided
if you let's say you have a Mars rover
hypothetically it er machined the metal
is cut at the Jet Propulsion lab in
Pasadena some of it the mirrors are
coated somewhere else the lenses are
ground somewhere else and these are all
done by companies but the fundamental I
I can read into this question shirt
there is no right now there's no
business model that takes people to Mars
there's no business model to find out
whether the core of Jupiter has hydrogen
that acts like a metal there's just no
reason for a private company to do that
at this time even though I'm very
curious well yes and let them reason
that don't put bread on a table Eugene
well you don't know that because you
might find something about the hydrogen
metal that would affect the way we make
semiconductors or microcircuits or
something yeah
with that said these things are all
built by contractors and the then the
crossover right now is the guys the
people who want to mine asteroids and at
first it sounds sexy and fabulous and
literally a shiny object to go to an
asteroid and get platinum yeah but
apparently the big thing they want to
get on ass
is water so you take water and then
yours fuel for your spaceship to keep
going so you have solar panels on your
spaceship your thing your spacecraft you
get out there to the asteroid you
electrolyze water make it hydrogen and
oxygen but somehow put it in a tank how
hard could it be in outer space I know
millions of kilometres from here yeah
and then you would have fuel to go on to
some other exotic destination maybe to
your platinum bearing asteroid and you
drag that back to the earth and get rich
ha ha ha ha ha
that's a pretty good plan alright so
here's a here's a question from Twitter
from Michael Christian he asks what kind
of private donation systems exists to
supplement funding NASA projects or
other planetary science research well
I'm sure this person is referring to the
Kickstarter program for start talk radio
wait or for a shuttle is there
Kickstarter to raise billions in oil
donation system I know is called taxes
can do really over I mean I don't we go
yep but they'll probably know I mean as
far as NASA goes NASA's but NASA gets
his budget based on the tax dollar but
the way that NPR various places that are
partially public partially private get
money is there a thing like that where
it could be like you know what I'm going
to give 7 billion dollars to NASA well
there is one that I know of and I'm not
an expert on all of them that there
might be but the arkad telescope this is
a idea where they're going to make
telescopes to look nominally to look for
asteroids but the proposal is to have
one pointed at the earth and then you
the user the online happy person can get
that telescope to point at anything you
want and it sounds very romantic to
Mount Everest but maybe you know your
neighbor's yard
it would have you so the lights are on
when you're away for example how it is a
way anyone can access it
anyone who's might understand the price
structure exactly but you give so much
money to arkad or AR KY d and they will
give you access to the telescope based
on some formula and I imagine do you
hear that very creepy people I don't
think I like this idea agency well so in
a dome over my house
well I don't know what the resolution
would be and how much value but what do
you do when you download Google Earth
and get it running on your computer
what's the first thing you do you lose
your house where all your exes live you
second gene I hear some of that touch
going to engines X's right there was
your gene anyway how many were you
talking about in round numbers a 100 to
300 yeah no normal all right here's
another question
Daniel segraves asks since our
government doesn't understand priorities
oh yeah I want to contribute to NASA
financially or otherwise otherwise I
don't know what he beats Edna bones what
is the most effective way to do so so
that's a similar question I would claim
the most effective way is to vote that
you hire people which can call
congressmen and Senators to make these
decisions and you hire them to figure
out where to send money to what so you
write them letters you call them you
could for example join the Planetary
Society at planetary org and we will
work to influence Congress to ensure
what about lobbyists I mean what do
people are there lots of people who hire
lobbyists yeah what contractors do yeah
contractors you're Lockheed you're
Boeing's I don't want to drop too many
names but we're going to have to take
another break and I encourage everyone
to check out the podcast on iTunes
I encourage out Facebook your Twitter
your Google Pinterest all the stuff the
kids are into ww star talk radio net we
will talk to you on the other side of
this break
welcome back to star talk radio Bill Nye
the Science Guy here guest hosting this
week on our cosmic queries edition of
Startalk here is always with eugene
mirman and special guest this week Mike
Massimino column mass a flew in space
now mass as we call you you are
following up on this question about how
do we participate in space because they
test financially or otherwise what are
other ways if any I'm not a financial
guy but otherwise I would suggest for
Daniel who asked the question and maybe
some of his friends too if you're
interested in the space program and want
to contribute
there's ways to contribute with your own
interests and your own energy and your
own efforts if you have a passion for
the space program which I assume he does
because yeah taking time to write as a
question yeah and whether he's
interested in science or math or if he's
interested in literature or art or
comedy in your case right you never and
you're interested in the space program
use your talents to promote the space
program to work on the space program get
a job an arrow get a job become an
engineer what's going in a shuttle or a
weapon and is a hey but there's a lot of
resources out there we can find out
what's going on in different parts of
the country different parts of the world
and and see what you can do to make it
part of your life I think that's the
best way to for a young person assume
maybe he's not a young person but I know
he is less than does adolescent so he's
probably have some age get involved and
do it I would say say he's over five
years over if he can write so he's ready
to go I want me to say about getting
involved yeah what getting involved in
space at least if you live in the u.s.
it means influencing NASA yes I'm
surprised more people don't hire a
lobbyist to jet like get together hire
lobbyists to just generally pressure all
Congress people to have more funding for
NASA well we do with the planetarium
you do so give you guys money and then
you'll hire all lobbyists we just need
we have two one we have one yeah but
what if you had five what if you had
there you go yeah I'm really now like
let's do this so well along that line as
you may know I did a little video an
open letter to the President of the
United States encouraging him to ensure
that we have funding for this niche it's
a line item within a line
item let's say NASA's a line item
planetary science is a line item I just
want them to fund it at a level high
enough to keep the current missions
flying you know we have Cassini flying
around Saturn messenger went to mercury
we got Juno going to Jupiter it's crazy
we got we got two Rovers on Mars and
those programs the the the Curiosity
rover all in developed over ten or you
could call it twelve years cost
one-and-a-half billion dollars that's
like one cup of coffee per taxpayer for
kryla and let me tell you something it
might that concerns me but stop helping
kids and little helping space is it a
good copy a good cup of coffee
well yeah fostering but let me say it's
one and a half billion dollars it's on
Mars and it's not even locked anybody
could just walk up to it I don't it's
shocking
so you have a low-tech to steal the
rover on Mars that would that's not a
bad contest oh my god somebody we'd have
to build a thing to go to land on Mars
you're quite an extraordinary Andre
sorry let me ask a question pay folks uh
unless you can get to Mars yeah that's
why it doesn't pay so expensive to get
to Mars right right it's not affordable
okay Gavin Buscher asks for his from
Melbourne Australia he asked do you
lament the lack of funding not just for
NASA but for science education in
general from a distance the other side
of the world it appears that America's
school science programs are not
receiving the backing that they should
and are under attack from other
influences such as religious and
political agendas if I were king nobody
did it is yes we would have more funding
for science but if I may let's not call
it Channel but speak on behalf of my
beloved colleague Neil deGrasse Tyson
who would normally be hosting star talk
radio if we had a robust space program
where investment was being made at a
higher level than it is now and we were
going to someplace new and cool with
people like Mass flying out into space
someplace new and exciting you wouldn't
need to run in circles screaming about
science technology engineering and math
which we like to call stem it would just
happen it would be it would be the real
trickle-down of science that is a real
thing
it would well not just science but
exploration right adventure and exactly
because there's two things that happen
Mass you've been up there you've done it
you when you go exploring two things you
get you're going to make discoveries
you're going to find things you never
found before the other thing you're
going to have Eugene yeah and yeah
adventure adventure oh yeah did you guys
when you were in space did you discover
anything were you were you like oh this
is a thing nobody knows about cheese
Betty wait actually it depends how you
look at it we were more or less the the
workers the maintenance people the
Hubble Space Telescope so yours we
didn't look through the telescope
mechanics it but our smart people here
on earth all the astronomers for example
Adam riess and a group of other
astronomers won a Nobel Prize the theory
of dark energy and dark matter came out
of Hubble oh wow observation photos what
you fell out of we fixed so we were more
like the repair people but you know
there's astounding discoveries that were
made but didn't you like some like a
cell just to see what we don't like our
own fun stuff like did you go like yeah
we're gonna fix the Hubble and while we
do this here's some like stakes and
shoes and let's see how rabbits how we
are on the mission you know candies and
statically yeah we did our own little
experiment but you know I play we played
baseballs baby wish them yeah did you
get walk in space and play baseball no
not I did I walked in space and I played
baseball separately hey when they play
baseball inside the cabin but we yeah we
did we did participate in some human
subject tests but the big science
objectives for us were to get Hubble fix
it discovered dark matter to discover
some really cool stuff they throw around
the term Dark Matter dark energy ever
throws it around like it's just
everything knows if that's an
extraordinary now but mass is the goal
prize-winning stuff so we got to take
another break we encourage you all to
enjoy your w w star talk radio net check
us out on Pinterest and check us out
right after this break
welcome back Bill Nye the Science Guy
here guest hosting star talk radio this
week the cosmic queries edition and
where we answer your questions Eugene
yes
you got another question I do from
Andrew Robles here we go scenario you're
in an elevator with a congressman who
has a lot of say over where tax money
gets spent you have one minute until the
elevator arrives at its destination what
examples of economic technological or
any other returns would you use to
convince him that space exploration is
worth funding more yes in with with a
minute to go I would say that it's going
to stimulate the economy mm-hmm with new
technology yeah new developments in the
science field it coming new new new
discoveries and materials and medicines
and so on it helps education because it
inspires young people yeah and it
promotes international cooperation
because we have our international space
station right other science programs and
it gives us something for our future
it's about exploration in our future yes
by my reckoning you did it by in 56
seconds yeah nice right now onto my
floor and I'm on my way but Bill what
would you say I'd say space exploration
brings out the best in us it's
inherently optimistic it stimulates the
economy in the u.s. at least three
dollars and sixty cents for every dollar
that goes in and we make discoveries
that literally change the world
astronomy has changed the world we found
that the earth goes around the Sun that
changed everything yeah we found the
sun's not unique first people were maybe
punished for it but yes
okay yeah but it did change the world
and now people throw around the
expression dark energy dark matter like
it's a day at the office but we all take
it for granted that there is such a
thing or such things and these were not
discovered even really 15 years ago who
knows what new physics who knows what
it's over the next horizon and
Congressman if I made to speak as a guy
born in the US and as a patriot don't
you want the u.s. to continue to lead in
this thing is that what you want mr.
congressman yeah miss congressman all
right here's another question from
Cameron US he wants to know how long if
at all before a manned mission to Titan
would this be a public or
private-sector venture yeah that's a
longer way out there
Titans as a long away how long would it
take to get to Titan weldable alright
with tension in your rocket ship
yeah but per se I'm using one long time
how long would that take five years
right that's a long time five years and
this is we don't have the technology
right now to stay away from all that
radiation it's not clear how bad that is
how much radiation enough to kill you
which isn't you probably don't want even
to kill a baby that maybe could adapt
more and so on well that's a lot of
world and you try to make it better but
babies that grow up and then know oh
it's a witch no that's not how a diaper
thing down a whole bunch of babies which
one made it through it have no trouble
wearing diapers yeah you a mass has been
there send like a twelve-year-old a
bunch of 12 year olds that will grow up
slowly during the mission but what we
are a genius
yeah you need to be you need to be
talking to that Congress from the
elevator mass how much trouble did you
have with bone loss calcium loss I'd
only been in my trips were two weeks at
a time Bill so it wasn't you but we've
got that licked we think but we've got
it licked through lots of exercise how
much do you lose you can lose a very
significant amount if you did nothing
yeah in space if you did not exercise
you could you would lose a lot how much
do you exercise when you go so in sprite
now to counteract that there is some
medicine you can take and that's again a
benefit of the space program because it
also applies to osteoporosis to prevent
bone loss but still the way we've gotten
around that we don't have bone loss it's
not an issue anymore but what we have to
do to counteract it is two hours of
exercise six days a week
oh wow so that's significant it's a lot
of times where you're on the payroll
there are sites in space there's
machines with resistance yes so there's
a good point because you can lift
weights all you want naked doing any
good in space right so what we have wait
a minute resistive XYZ you're like
hercules bill yeah but it's always nice
to crush you that's right you try less
basically like that that's the way it
starts that's sometimes a way it's
subscribed when it's on the fritz be
careful of the thing but it works on
Springs and Thera bands like you might
have seen in rehab medicine so it's a
resistive exercise plus it's also a
treadmill is generally a popular way to
exercise so it's both cardio and it's
also resistive exercise and it's
resistive exercise
that keeps your bones in good shape ah
and to this question yes it's it's a
long way and who's paying for its a lot
of fuel yeah
do we have another question fearless
leader we we do uh so uh Justin Foley
asks how do you see cubes
cube SATs and other small spacecraft
affecting space exploration I think
these things are great Bell it's a cool
thing what's the game chat is a small
experiment that can be flown by
universities I think high school
students have been centimeters by 10
centimeters by 10 centimeters so that
while it's fantastic there was a great
opportunity so their standard rate for
education they fit on a standard
launcher ring they go off from a
standard spring-loaded gizmo and I
cannot point out the Planetary Society
is going to fly to solar sails stick
with us there there are Cube sets that
will be deployed in space to see if we
can develop technology to fly good stuff
well to other planets without any fuel
so I'll have to talk more but yes we
will talk more about that on on the
other side of this break please stay
tuned to star talk radio
welcome back to star talk radio Bill Nye
the Science Guy here guest hosting this
week on the cosmic queries edition now
Eugene yeah I wonder how to worry about
CubeSat so so you're like app
universities gonna have them what is it
how do you make it how much do they cost
there are 10 centimeters by 10
centimeters by 10 centimeters very small
fit in a lunchbox and it's a standard
that can be launched from a standard
system on board a standard rocket and so
you can launch generally seven at a time
universities make these things you can
buy the circuit boards and software
online can a person launch it or you
need a rocket well these things still
cost million dollars that's a lot of
money but you get a grant okay so the
program you can apply for a grant to
NASA and then and if your grant is
accepted and you have fun to do it then
you build your project fly it in space
and well it's great it's a great way to
it's a it's a relatively inexpensive way
to explain what to explore space just
put it this way if your grants accepted
nice alright let's do a light brings us
to the lightning round
alright a few seconds per question tears
a question dire male wants to know would
it be possible to host a music festival
on a radio satellite for a quote hip
promotional event is there a way NASA
could start a nationwide door-to-door
survey to get people to sign a petition
to raise the NASA budget that sounds
like a two-part question and I think if
you got a corporation involved excited
about your music they could that
corporation could easily fund such a
satellite the big problem will be
getting a license and so it's all
solvable problems yeah I get out there
and do it
yeah all right here we go uh Chakra
wants to know do we really have to
choose between Cassini and curiosity I
don't want to lose either
we at the Planetary Society are
petitioning the US government to not
have to make that choice though there
should be enough funding for planetary
science a line item within the NASA
budget to fund both missions that the
Cassini is out there your much money
we've invested that time effort and
energy for crying out loud we've got to
keep them both lying okay here we go
Debbie large wants to know why isn't
there more
news coverage of science advancement
when I was a kid all networks had a
science correspondent that's true what
the hell well now there's a whole
channel called a science show yeah but
why not yeah but that's for people
already like science or wanna watch
toilets get built and how it works at a
factory what about like uh whatever like
good like NBC what about major networks
being like this is the weather and this
is today's science I guess I guess it
doesn't sell well enough or else a would
have it yeah there's other sources for
that information mostly online we
recommend planetary door guy just did a
fabulous thing with IFLS I won't spell
that out just go check it out because
they it's the news of science I think it
could be I think it's a shame that it's
not seen as a more interesting topic or
maybe more entertaining the three-level
fix it yeah we need to that's what we're
trying to do now but I agree it should
be more in the mainstream okay I think
it could be I think so Jimmy class
Manson wants to know since China is now
sending robots to the moon does the u.s.
have any plans of doing the same not
right now there are congressmen and
Senators who insist that the u.s. go
back to the moon in some fashion there
are other people that insist that the
moon is a big gravity well and no we
should go beyond it to start with mass
you have an opinion I think we should go
with the Chinese if we could I think
it'd be a nice thing to cooperate yeah
I'll be fun fabulous all right here we
go Andreea hum ray wants to know what
are you most hopeful about when it comes
to humanity's relationship with the
earth I'm most hopeful that people will
find ways to innovate and engineer the
entire planet I think that's the future
as the human population continues to
increase and our scientifically
scientific literacy increases worldwide
through education I think more people
that get to see the Earth from space
particularly artists and so on that are
hopefully gonna have the opportunity we
could only complain about enough I think
I think it's it increases your
appreciation how beautiful the planet is
so that's my end right on alright Daniel
Sprouse wants to know bill why don't you
run for office Bill Nye the Science
POTUS has a nice ring to it
oh sure so Neil deGrasse Tyson
and I are working on our cabinet on who
who would have would you yeah do you
guys want to court jester court jester
yeah no wait you why'd you take wait a
sec I would be more fun job are you be
the court jester I'll be the engineering
a advisor advisor we're a package team
haha exactly alright oh wait as this is
those are from the beginning here's a
question so Stephen Stafford wants to
know how do I get the people in my life
to see the importance of space
exploration I try my best to spread the
word and show the wonders of our
universe but no one seems to care also
I'm a very port student and can't afford
a membership to the Planetary Society
think you can help me out mr. Knight I I
don't know why you're having trouble
influencing people it sounds like you
are pretty convincing guy stick with it
ah all right here we go here's a
question from Nick clarity NASA is
sending us back to the moon quote for
good and also for preparation for Mars
how much actual engineering on the moon
will prepare us for Mars can we really
learn what we need for Mars from the
moon or is it a waste of money I refer
of course I heart context Johnston the
test pilot on the very first 7:07
airplane who remarked one test is worth
a thousand expert opinions let's go try
it I think the moon is our playground
and we can learn a tremendous amount but
stop again on our way to Mars yeah yep
how hard could it be and Europe this has
been this has been a fabulous cosmic
queries edition of star talk radio I
want to thank my guests Mike Massino
mass closer that's lots of Musa Dagh ma
ug Nitin we've got a good agenda why I
put my entire life I've been cold mass
that's we're out of time uh you guys
were out of time Eugene Mirman spelled
just like Mir yeah the Russian and slash
world man station so join us next time
on Startalk radios we work together to
dare I say it change the world
this is Startalk